but make no mistake this radical
ideology is being driven
by white progressives who in so doing or
cultivating
a false sense of victimhood none more so
than megan rapino do you megan repino
is a lady she's a soccer player i guess
and she has silly colored hair and she's
very
very left-wing megan rapino was just
speaking at the white house
and she as she's speaking there right
she's a fairly well-known person she's
fairly rich
she's speaking at the white house she
just had to complain
i'm a member of the lgbtq community
with pink hair and where i come from i
could have only dreamed that i would be
standing in the position i am today at
the white house
excuse me hold on she just said hi
i'm a lesbian and i've got silly colored
hair and i'm a liberal activist
uh not totally surprising and i could
have only dreamed that i'd be here what
are you talking about
the dominant regime is explicitly
telling us
women are better than men the presidents
that women are better than men we're
told that
straight white men are the the bane of
all existence you know they're the the
source of of evil in the world
we're told that uh unusual sexual
desires are much better than
straight sexual desires what are you
you're you are the exact person
who would be standing there at the white
house she goes on to complain even more
i'm also a professional athlete and i've
helped
along with all of my teammates virtually
here
today one teammate literally here today
uh win four world cup championships
and four olympic gold medals for the
united states
and despite those wins i've been
devalued
i've been disrespected and dismissed
because i am a woman
and i've been told that i don't deserve
any more
than less because i am a woman
you see despite all the wins i'm still
paid less than men who do the same job
that i do
for each trophy of which there are many
and for each win for each tie and for
each time that we play
it's less and i know there are millions
of people who
are marginalized by gender in the world
and experience the same thing in their
jobs and i know that there are people
who experience
even more where the layers of
discrimination
continue to stack against them so
nothing she just said is true she's not
paid less for doing the same job she
does a different job she doesn't play
men's soccer if she played men's soccer
she would have never made it onto a high
school team because men are better
athletes than women because they're
bigger and stronger and faster
and that's just a fact of nature and you
can't change that nature
she's never been devalued she's
extraordinarily overvalued the president
of the united states
is standing there listening to this
woman babble on and complain
she's rich she's famous specifically for
her identity politics
and yet she brags and boasts and i've
got all these trophies
ugly ugly pride and then whines and
complains even more
ugly pride and a sort of a a false sense
of victimhood
how on earth anybody would would
associate themselves with political
views
that this sort of woman is preaching but
she knows that that victimhood has
currency and i think that
is the sort of cynical reason that a lot
of people go along with it is they know
that if they can
claim any sort of grievance any sort of
victimhood no matter how ridiculous like
this woman's
then they can get a certain advantage in
the society very
very ugly stuff if you enjoyed that
video be sure to hit the subscribe
button so everyone waiting through the
wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there